[Music]
kyle starts us off this hour in
manchester new hampshire hey kyle how
are you
hey sir i'm doing great how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so my mom is 57 years old
she's
losing her job next month
she's been working at a company for 22
years
and i'm looking to have a discussion
with her about her plans for retirement
she so far has been unwilling to
share her financial situation with me
and discuss her retirement plan
so far
she has she told me that she's been
she's going to put it off it's too soon
to think about retirement
and uh i just would like to open up that
conversation with her and get her
sort of on track for that
okay
why do you think she's unwilling to talk
to you about it
i sat down with her and asked her
you know what her what her plan was i'm
her only son i'm also a little nervous
that
it's going to fall on me
but she told me that her parents never
talked to her about retirement or their
financial situation and that she doesn't
want to talk
about her financial situation with me
being her son
okay
that's her only reasoning
she might be embarrassed
to talk about it as well i think that's
the real reason
it sucks and she doesn't want to own it
she's ashamed
yeah
i i think
i really feel like i could help her by
giving her tools
to do better with her financial
situation so that she could have a
stress stress-free retirement someday
it's almost like she doesn't anticipate
on retiring ever that she's just going
to work
until the end
yeah that's a hard conversation i know
that you know i'm the person that talks
to both my in-laws and my mom a lot
about money and i found that one of the
best ways is not to just tell to not
just say hey this is what i should do
but to bring them in so it sounds like
you're pretty um on top of your finances
and so i wonder if you could just even
you know kind of talk to her about what
you're doing so she doesn't feel that
that shame and that you know finger
pointing at her but it's more like hey
this is what i'm excited about right now
this is what i'm doing this is what i'm
stoked about do you want to come with me
to an event do you want to read a book
with me or watch a video and just see if
it can kind of be an enthusiastic thing
versus a shame based thing exactly yeah
the best way you can enter something
like this and and
i learned this accidentally because i
went broke
and then i started telling people about
the story of going broke and then that
they gave me because i gave because i
did that
they didn't feel as stupid because i was
bigger stupid and right standing right
in front of them right
and so then i could call them stupid and
call them out but i was doing that from
a position of my negative story not i've
got it all together and you people are a
bunch of doofuses right it was more like
i've got a phd in dumb and i've done a
lot of stupid and that drops the shame
down
the gate down and allows me to walk into
people's lives i didn't even know i was
doing it i figured it out 10 years after
i first started doing it probably before
i realized what was happening was that
god had given me the story of going
broke this wonderful story and
it's wonderful to hear but not wonderful
to live and um you know and basically
i'm running around the country for 30
years telling people how dumb i was with
money hey i got an idea how to help you
with your money and seems it seems
oxymoronic but it what it did is it took
the shame barrier down now how's that
translate to you just exactly like
christina said it's you probably ought
to say you know mom i was scared about
this for a long time
because i didn't know anything about it
and i hadn't done a very good job and i
felt really bad
i felt ashamed
and here's you know here's what i
started doing i started doing this and
then i felt a little better and then i
started doing that and i felt a little
better
and uh if you've if you've not done a
good job with retirement mom that just
makes you like a normal person
and so i there's no shame in it i i
messed it up and i'm trying to figure it
out and if you want to learn some of the
stuff i've learned it would be my honor
to walk alongside and to teach and to
help you with that but
i'm not here to look down on my nose at
you and saying you've done a horrible
job
i'm just here to say i did a horrible
job too
because i didn't know what i was doing
either
and i had to figure it out and that's
approach it from
bottom up rather than top down
and it's what most the financial people
mess up on they drop their glasses down
the end of their nose and wag their
finger at somebody
and talking down to them instead of
going hey man i've screwed up so i know
what stupid looks like
and so then you got permission to call
out stupid once you've done that but
you've got to establish that because
she's
um
she's probably a pretty proud woman it
sounds like
and um
yeah the shame that she's feeling is
what is holding her off it's not that
her dad didn't talk about money it says
she doesn't have any money
and she is going to be working up to 70
years old probably because she's
probably broke
and so if you can help her with that
then you'll get her on the way
um let me send you a copy of baby steps
millionaires
and you can give her how ordinary people
build extraordinary wealth how you can
too you can give it to her and just say
hey i read this book and this was all
stuff i didn't know
and it blew my mind and because i felt
so dumb and just keep talking about how
dumb you are
that's a real good idea just to get the
conversation started and because it just
drops the shame barrier down yeah and i
think it's so important to just make
sure you tell her that there's no dumb
questions there are no questions that
are too silly i think even as many
people we're constantly asking questions
and there's constantly things that i
don't know that i'm learning and i think
some of the wisest people are willing to
admit you know
they don't know things so it's like no
matter where you are in your financial
journey whether you're brand new you
don't know anything about retirement or
you're you know you've read every ramsey
book there is be willing to ask
questions and be okay if you sound a
little bit silly in the process yeah but
she's not there right now she just all
bottled up with shame she just stopped
up
and so to kind of get the top off of it
get your flow going a little bit and is
just just start talking about how talk
about you don't talk about her and don't
talk about anything except how scared
you were and how inept you were and how
ignorant you were and i had to get to
learning about this stuff and boy i sure
do feel better now that i've learned
about it still don't have it all figured
out but i know a lot i know enough now
that i'm not scared and i don't feel
dumb and man i felt so dumb and i was so
scared and you know those and that those
should be truthful statements by the way
i'm guessing they are i doubt you uh
20 years old had it all together maybe
you did a few of those people call here
but not most of us didn't most of us
have stumbled around looking stupid for
a while yeah and they're hard
conversations to have but good for you
for being willing to go there with your
mom and support her and love her that
way
that's awesome the only other thing you
could do is get someone that she
considers a peer or she looks up to
that would speak into her life and jog
this loose
and that might be an uncle that might be
a
grandparent that might be a pastor i
don't know someone who's in a position
of credibility that you don't have